Big data, health informatics, and
bioinfomatics, are some of the
buzz words that you have heard these days.
What is bioinfomatics? Why is it important?
And, how can we use bioinfomatics to
solve some of the problems that we face
everyday? These are some of the questions that
we will attempt to address in this lecture.
In 1799 while constructing a fort in Egypt, a
group of French soldiers came across an ancient
Egyptian tablet containing hieroglyphics
on it. What made the discovery this tablet
so ground breaking was not just the
fact that it contained hieroglyphics,
because by this point quite a few stones without
script had already been discovered. It was what
came with the hieroglyphics that made the
stone so important to Greek. Because while
for over a thousand years no one has been
able to read the ancient Egyptian script,
but everyone trained in classical languages could
read Greek. This discovery 40 years later enabled
the French scholar to find a way to decode the
meaning of the hieroglyphics, the symbols which
have been silent for over a millennium became a
new window into ancient Egyptian life and culture.
Today, we are faced with a challenge and an
opportunity similar to that of the rosetta
stone. It comes from a language which
works in any human language in the
immense number of volumes written in
it, and that is the language of DNA.
DNA contains the blueprints for every biological
process of every living thing on earth,
and even a small defect in the genetic code
can cause devastating health consequences.
Understanding how genes work, both
individually and with each other is
crucial to the development of the twenty
first century personalized medicine.
However, the problem is that even when we
actually have an organism's DNA in front of us,
we are not be possible to sift through
it with an army of people to understand
it. It is often not easy to tell when an
individual gene does. Even more difficult is
to tease out the subtle influences that multiple
genes have on each other. But, answering those
kinds of questions is foundational to attacking
genetically influenced diseases at the root cause.
Today, new high-throughput technologies bring
unprecedented opportunities for life science
research. They allow us to get new data never seen
before, to study new questions impossible to study
before, and to discover new phenomena unimaginable
before. Now we can sequence not only one person’s
genome, but also many different people’s genomes.
This allows us to study the genetic differences
between different people at genome scale, as well
as many other questions in population genetics.
At the same time, we can also study the
genetic differences between patients
and normal controls to find the genetic
mutations responsible for some of the diseases.
In addition to the human genome, over
1000 trillion base pairs from over 165,000
species had been sequenced by the end of 2013.
Just reading them would take 30 million years.
Life science data is not only big in size, but
also growing exponentially. This figure shows
the number of nucleotides sequenced and
stored in the Genbank database over year.
The number of nucleotides had been increasing
exponentially since 1982, doubling every 20
months. What does this mean? It means that
the data deposited into Genbank in the next 20
months from now on is as much as all the data that
have existed in the history of human till today.
At the same time, the sequencing cost had been
decreasing every year. The past few years had seen
even steeper growth of sequencing data. The reason
is that next-generation sequencing technologies
had been developed and used more and more widely
in all areas of life sciences. Next-generation
sequencing technologies can sequence one person’s
genome in a day with less than 2000 dollars.
Just think about what exciting discoveries
these never-seen-before data may contain!
Other than sequencing data, other
high-throughput technologies such
as proteomic, metabolomic and et cetera,
had also generated a large variety of data.
Other than sequencing data, other
high-throughput technologies such
as proteomic, metabolomic and et cetera,
had also generated a large variety of data.
With great opportunities come great challenges.
The huge amount of data requires efficient
methods. Exponential growth requires scalable
methods. The low signal-to-noise ratio requires
accurate methods. And handling multiple types
of data requires data integrative methods. These
are significant technical challenges. But,
it depends on how you look at it. Technical
challenges can also mean opportunities
for technical innovations. The birth and
growth of the field of bioinfomatics has been
driven by these opportunities and challenges.
As you may be able to realize by now, the
integration between life science and computer
science is inevitable, and the result is the
birth and growth of the field of bioinfomatics.
Bioinfomatics can be defined as an
interdisciplinary field that develops
and applies computer and computational
technologies to study biomedical questions.
It has two roles. As a technology, bioinfomatics
is a powerful technology to manage,
search, and analyze big data in life sciences.
As a methodology, bioinfomatics is a top-down
holistic, data-driven, genome-wide, and systems
approach that generates new hypotheses, finds new
patterns, and discovers new functional elements.
It complements traditional experimental
biology methods. A seamless combination
of computational and experimental methods should
be the best way to study a biological question.
Bioinformatics is truly interdisciplinary.
It studies questions in biology and medicine,
while developing and applying methods in computer
sciences, mathematics, statistics, and physics.
It overlaps with medical and clinical informatics,
systems biology, and synthetic biology.
The Bio in bioinformatics signifies the biological
questions it studies, many of which can be
grouped under the conceptual framework from
genotype to phenotype and the Central Dogma.
Some examples may help you understand
better. For instance, sequence alignment.
Are the sequences of two genes or proteins
similar? Could they be homologous? How can
we find the closest homologue of the gene
we are studying from the vast databases?
Can I use the known function of a known gene
to guide the study of my gene of interest?
Given DNA and genome sequences, how can we find
the genes in the vast genome? How can we compare
the similarity and difference between two whole
genomes and reconstruct the evolutionary history?
What are the syntenic regions between two
genomes? How can we identify which genomic
regions are methylated? At the level of RNA
expression, we often need to find out which genes
are differentially expressed between two organs
or tissues, between tumor and normal tissues,
or between two different developmental stages?
At the level of proteins, how do you identify
the expressed proteins from mass spec data?
Proteins do not exist in a linear form in nature.
Instead, they are folded into beautiful
three dimensional structures in nature.
How can we predict the three-dimensional
structure of a protein from its sequence?
Molecules do not exist or function in isolation.
Instead, they form complex molecular network.
How can we construct protein-protein interaction
network, transcription regulation networks,
and metabolic and signaling pathways? What
are the dynamic features of these networks?
Furthermore, with these data and researches,
how can we simulate a virtual cell?
Last but not least, how do you compare different
people’s genomes and use population genetic
approaches to compare the genomes of the ill
and the healthy, and identify the gene mutations
that cause diseases? From these examples, we
can see that there are many interesting and
important questions in life sciences that
await our bioinformatics investigation.
Seeing bioinformatics from another angle,
the informatics in Bioinformatics signifies the
information and computational methods to manage,
search, and analyze the data. The theme runs
along the axis from data to discovery. First,
the storage, index, and search of terabytes to
petabytes of big data require advanced databases.
Just imagine, your laptop probably
has several Gigabytes of hard disk.
However just one set of our experiments often
generates one or more terabytes of data,
which is too large to fit in your laptop. Managing
such big data requires advanced database systems.
Analysis of noisy big data requires
the development of many algorithms,
software tools, and web servers. These make
up a big portion of bioinformatics research.
A tradition in bioinformatics since the
early days till today has been to make most
algorithms and software open source. This
has contributed significantly to the broader
life science research, and had helped to advance
bioinformatics itself as well. With these tools,
we can do a lot of data mining to discover
new patterns and phenomena in life science.
Finally, by integration of data and tools, we can
build predictive models of biological systems.
As more and more high-throughput technologies
are used more and more in life science, there
will continue to be numerous new opportunities
for technology innovation in bioinformatics.
To meet this challenge, a new breed of
professional that could collaborate and
communicate with biomedical researchers,
clinicians, quantitative scientists and
bioethicists is needed to translate the
genomic knowledge to improve patient outcomes.
In summary, bioinformatics is central
to molecular life-science research.